i usually feel pretty good about being
in my 30s and where i've gotten in my
life but then i met the person who
painted these take a look this is a
skyler grey's work he's an incredibly
talented street artist who's only 13
13 years old and his art is in galleries
and i actually had a chance to hang out
with skyler and he taught me a lot about
life and art and how to paint myself so
why don't we watch something that we
filmed earlier now that i'm in the room
with you
i'm sitting here with the fresh prince
of street art my man skylar gray already
one of the coolest people i've ever met
well thank you one of the coolest person
people i've ever met thank you you're
very
cool
i think we got everything we need
what's better seeing art in a museum or
seeing art in the street
um i like artistry because if i see art
on the street it's like street it's like
city beautification it's almost like
life is art right if you participate
with life in the right way whatever
you're doing could be art if you're
doing it to its fullest expression art
is a language and they took since they
took art out of schools yeah a lot of
kids don't speak that language all they
really care about is hey you met this
rapper yesterday how was he was he cool
so can i just point out 13
bringing art back to schools
1-3 putting together like a political
and beautifully put message what is your
deal
i don't understand
when i was 13 i was like farting into a
pringle scan to pin my friend's sister
down and open it in her face
that's a true story do you read uh
reviews or anything like that
yeah um say i have a
article written down on me i probably
look down on
on
the comments and i think like is that
what they really think about me but i'm
just gonna go i'm gonna do something
better i'm gonna go harder
that's right
genuinely inspiring
because
can we swear for he's a child for forget
them
forget them what are they doing that's
so mother forgetful great
they could stay in their freaking garage
stay in your freaking garage you forget
faces
i heard you like cleveland you want to
do cleveland with me oh that's nasty
i can do more kermit the problem hey
guys some kermit
can i just bring it down
now bring it up hey guys
ray romano
skyler i would be honored we brought
some pictures of me that we could paint
around if if you'd be willing to do that
no i wanted to do it for you man for you
let's do it
and what we'll do is we'll make a border
order we're not on it but not around it
i want you to border you did it all
around yeah and right here and yeah you
pay on the side of me
see for for money reasons we can't have
music actually playing if we can cut the
background track listen
right
we just got the traffic
is this going so well you will never
want to paint without me
i guess
i think what i like about your style is
there is no
mistakes it's just like there's no
limits to art there's no limits there's
a there's an interaction there's a flow
and it's awesome to watch you get into
that
and i've also never been able to grow
sideburns so this is a big thrill
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pick one color
i'm going to do one color and i'm going
to take another color i'm going to blend
it in
how are you doing i don't know
you look like a pirate astronaut
grab a piece of napkin yeah give me one
okay and put it on the side a little
drips on the side no it's right here
yeah
this one doesn't matter it could just
put it anywhere yeah and then what you
can do is take the napkin in
oh
adjustable layers
layers layers layers happy
word of the day layers layers after we
do this
we're gonna have to get to our logo
right all right we'll make your logo
yeah where do you put your logo usually
i'll put it on the side on either side
but
here i'll put it right here wait maybe
my
logo should be the pringles can
it should be
okay and then we'll keep it open have a
little fart come out of it
look i'm sandra bullock in gravity
no one will know what that says except
us
yours is awesome
that is so good
i can see why you're where you are and
i'll just be
you know
you have some more drapes to it
i don't think drips are going to save
money
kyle gray everybody
yeah
that was awesome man thank you thank you
so much
you